[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista con a France
24 nos encontramos con la presidenta de
kosovoglosa Osmani Muchas gracias
presidenta por estar aquí con nosotros
hoy Gracias presidenta la guerra empezó
hace 25 años usted es abogada fue una
refugiada
cuan profundas son las cicatrices de ese
terrible conflicto
primero que todo gracias por invitarme
es un placer poder hablar con ustedes
han pasado casi 24 años desde que
terminó la guerra y casi 15 años desde
que declaramos nuestra independencia y
las heridas en kosovo son muy profundas
porque los crímenes que cometió el
régimen de mielosevich iban más allá de
la imaginación humana fueron crímenes de
guerra crímenes de lesa humanidad y
genocidio Y esa es la razón por la que
la otan intervino debido a esos
continuos crímenes pero el pueblo de ha
demostrado ser extremadamente resistente
y hemos construido todo de la nada y de
las cenizas el país quedó completamente
destruido no hay una sola familia que no
haya pasado por un infierno o que no
haya perdido algún Familiar o que no
tenga algún familiar que haya
desaparecido forzosamente o que no haya
perdido su casa
las heridas también son muy profundas
porque no ha habido justicia para las
víctimas los autores siguen estando
libres en Serbia por la mayoría de los
crímenes cometidos y al mismo tiempo hay
casi 2.000 personas desaparecidas
forzosamente en kosovo que están en
fosas comunes en Serbia
este mes se celebran también los 15 años
de la declaración de Independencia
Serbia Rusia y cinco países miembros de
la Unión Europea Siguen sin reconocer a
kosovo como un país independiente Por
qué no se ha encontrado una solución
primero que todo yo no metería a Rusia y
Serbia en el mismo grupo que los cinco
países de la Unión Europea que no nos
reconocen porque los dos primeros Rusia
y Serbia no reconocen a kosovo porque
tienen ideas hegemónicas e imperialistas
lo mismo pasa con Rusia y las antiguas
repúblicas de la unión soviética las ve
como países temporales y tiene
reclamaciones territoriales contra ellas
servía hace lo mismo contra sus vecinos
aquí en los balcanes occidentales Serbia
quiere vernos a nosotros y abonearse
bovina y Montenegro y a otros países
como estados temporales y volver a los
años 90 a través de sus reclamaciones
territoriales contra nosotros que son
ideas hegemónicas que pertenecen al
pasado eso en cuanto a esos dos países
en cuanto a los cinco países que no han
reconocido a kosovo creo que vamos por
buen camino y se encontrará una solución
donde estos países no dudarán de nuestra
adhesión la independencia de kosovo es
un hecho Irreversible Así que estamos
aquí para seguir siendo un país
independiente y soberano Sólo es
cuestión de tiempo lo rápido que algunos
países formalicen su decisión de
reconocernos hablando de esto votaría a
favor la unión de kosovo con Albania
como han dicho en el pasado algunos
miembros del gobierno actual
my stands husband same Mi voto y mi
postura han sido los mismos desde que
empecé a entender la política siendo muy
pequeña nos hemos sacrificado y hemos
trabajado por un kosovo independiente y
soberano y mi trabajo seguirá estando
dedicado únicamente a un kosovo
independiente y soberano
la declaración de Independencia y la
Constitución de la República de kosovo
son el principio y el fin de todo lo que
hago y creo que la República de kosovo
está aquí para quedarse para siempre no
es un proyecto temporal es un proyecto
permanente y es la voluntad del pueblo
de kosovo
la guerra terminó pero los disparos no
existe el peligro de una nueva escalada
hay una sola parte que dispara había una
sola parte que disparaba en los años 90
y hay una sola parte que dispara ahora y
es Serbia Serbia es la única fuente de
inestabilidad en los balcanes
occidentales si uno recorre la región y
le pregunta a cualquiera de los países
si les preocupa la posibilidad de ser
atacados por kógogo o por Bosnia o por
Albania macedonia o Montenegro todos
dirán que no porque ninguno de nosotros
el resto de nosotros está atacando a
nadie solo hay un país que nos preocupa
a todos debido a su reivindicaciones
territoriales y es Serbia que lidera
continuamente los esfuerzos de
desestabilización sirviendo a los
intereses de Putin y de Rusia para
desestabilizar los balcanes occidentales
de forma que luchemos contra los
sistemas basados en valores que son la
Unión Europea y la otan porque Rusia
sabe e históricamente Ese ha sido su
interés que si se desestabilizan los
balcanes occidentales No puede haber una
Europa unida libre y en paz
nuestros países están tan
interconectados que si hay conflictos y
tensiones en una parte del continente
todo el continente de una u otra manera
se ve afectado de la misma manera que
está ocurriendo ahora por la guerra en
Ucrania y eso es lo que Rusia pretende
expandir el conflicto para poder desviar
la atención de occidente de Ucrania a
otras partes del continente también
la guerra en Ucrania está poniendo
presión a esta región
Rusia está presionando a través de
Serbia desde el 24 de febrero los
esfuerzos de Rusia y Serbia para
desestabilizar la región han aumentado
no han disminuido sino que han aumentado
porque como lo dije antes Rusia ha
intentado históricamente desestabilizar
los balcanes occidentales
porque cuantas más tensiones creen a
través de Serbia menos posibilidades
tendrán los países de los balcanes
occidentales de unirse a la Unión
Europea todos entendemos que Europa por
fin estará en paz y el proyecto de
Europa unida libre y en paz se logrará
si los balcanes occidentales se adhieren
a la Unión Europea Así que Rusia Está
tratando de impedirlo Y lamentablemente
está aprovechando esa oportunidad a
través de Serbia que es un país que está
permitiendo esa influencia maligna
especialmente Durante los últimos 10
años
tiene una gran base militar de Estados
Unidos
es Washington su mejor Aliado Washington
Washington es el Aliado más importante y
estratégico de la República de kosovo y
consideramos que esta Alianza es
esencial para preservar la paz y la
seguridad que hemos alcanzado así como
para defender nuestra libertad y nuestra
independencia por supuesto además de
Washington hay muchas naciones europeas
y no europeas democracias de todo el
mundo que se unieron para defender las
libertades básicas contra la tiranía y
contra el genocidio creo que el éxito de
kosovo es el mayor éxito de la política
exterior de estas democracias de las
democracias occidentales y así Debería
ser visto también hoy por eso Putin lo
odia odia el éxito de kosovo
es la Encarnación misma de lo que las
democracias pueden lograr cuando se unen
para ayudar a un pueblo oprimido a
conseguir su libertad y contra las
tiranías y hegemonías creo que el
ejemplo y el modelo de kosovo deberían
servir a las democracias Incluso en la
actualidad Para apoyar al pueblo
ucraniano tal y como es de forma muy
unida pero también a los pueblos
oprimidos de otras partes del mundo Así
que sí Washington es nuestro Aliado
existencial pero las democracias de todo
el mundo también son nuestros aliados y
estamos trabajando duro para asegurarnos
de que creemos más amigos y socios y
aliados porque ese es el camino para
intensificar aún más la cooperación pero
también para fortalecer nuestra
democracia así como nuestra posición
internacional
Confía en los países europeos
Sí desde luego si no confiamos en Europa
no nos esforzaríamos tanto por unirnos
al resto de Naciones europeas dentro de
la Unión Europea a veces pienso que
algunos de los métodos que eligen frente
a Serbia no son los correctos porque
históricamente han demostrado ser
erróneos por ejemplo no estoy de acuerdo
con la política activa de apaciguamiento
que muchos en la Unión Europea no todos
para ser exactos pero sí Muchos emplean
con Serbia porque los métodos de
apaciguamiento hacia los autócratas han
demostrado traer más devastación y no
más Paz o estabilidad en este sentido
Por supuesto que tenemos conversaciones
abiertas y honestas con nuestros socios
y aliados europeos pero no me cabe la
menor duda ni a ninguno de los
ciudadanos de kosovo que Europa es el
lugar al que pertenecemos
aquí geográficamente estamos aquí por
identidad pero lo más importante es que
pertenecemos a Europa porque somos una
extensión de esos valores los mismos
valores sobre los que se fundó la Unión
Europea y llevamos siglos defendiendo
esos valores incluso antes de que se
fundara la Unión Europea fue nuestra
nación la que luchó por lo que entonces
se llamaba la civilización europea
qué responde a aquellos que señalan los
problemas de collabo con la corrupción
con el crimen organizado
Cuál es cuál es su respuesta a estas
críticas que les hacen
está claro que eso era el pasado en
kosovo ciertamente no es el presente y
así lo han confirmado varias
organizaciones e índices internacionales
en los que kosovo como dije ha subido 20
puestos en solo los dos últimos años en
la lucha contra la delincuencia
organizada y la corrupción De hecho no
vacilo en afirmar que kosovo está muy
por delante de todos los países de la
región en lo que se refiere a la lucha
contra la delincuencia y la corrupción y
yo diría que incluso de algunos países
de la Unión Europea Así que según el
índice de Estado de derecho kosovo es el
segundo reformador del mundo en lo que
se refiere al Estado de derecho la lucha
contra la delincuencia y la corrupción y
es el primer reformador de todo el
continente europeo Esa es mi respuesta
quienes pueden estar diciendo eso aunque
un observador honesto y objetivo nunca
diría eso de kosovo
hay muchos rumores sobre el diálogo con
Serbia están negociando en este momento
el proceso nunca se ha detenido salvo
que en cada momento se utilizan métodos
diferentes en este momento se está
llevando a cabo la llamada diplomacia
itinerante en la que los negociadores
viajan a veces a pristina a veces a
Belgrado y negocian con cada uno por
separado además hay ocasiones en las que
se celebran reuniones de alto nivel en
Bruselas Esperamos que una de esas
reuniones se lleve a cabo este mes pero
los intermediarios de la Unión Europea
deben fijar la fecha exacta por nuestra
parte kosovo ha mostrado su disposición
a acudir a Bruselas siempre que se nos
invita y hemos mostrado nuestra
disposición no solo a estar presentes
sino también hacer extremadamente
constructivos con ideas y propuestas que
contribuyan a una paz duradera pero al
fin y al cabo depende de los
negociadores de la Unión Europea cuando
consideren oportuno convocar estas
reuniones y Esperamos que continúen
pronto
presidenta Muchas gracias por esta
entrevista y suerte en su trabajo es
usted la segunda mujer presidenta de su
país
Muchas gracias Se lo agradezco y les
deseo lo mejor
[Música]